Chile was once the most stable and prosperous
country in Latin America.
A role model.
A kind of experiment to show that escaping
poverty isn’t an impossible goal, even in
Latin America.
However, in October 2019, this model seemed
to begin to shatter.
Suddenly waves of extreme violence and huge
political mobilizations erupted throughout
the country.
Within just a few weeks, the country was on
fire.
Since the protests started, 26 people have
lost their lives; thousands have been wounded,
more than 25,000 premises have been affected
by fires, looting or destruction, the Santiago
metro has suffered damage worth hundreds of
millions of dollars and the economy has stopped.
To give you an idea, according to government
data, the cost of these damages run between
two and three billion dollars.
Dear friends of VisualPolitik, in this video
we’ll tell you what happened in Chile, why
it happened and what lies ahead.
Listen up.
(THE SPARK THAT LIT THE FIRE)
The October social explosion was a surprise
that caught everyone off guard.
Check this out, the turning point came when
the Chilean government decided to increase
the price of the Santiago metro ticket by
30 pesos, about $US 0.04.
Yes, I know, it wasn't exactly a huge increase...
But let's say that was the reason, the motive,
the spark that lit the fire.
Suddenly hundreds of students began to protest,
entering the subway without paying... but
it didn’t stop there.
Little by little everything got out of hand.
Look, we’re talking about Monday October
14th, well, by Saturday 19th the subway was
on fire:
Yes, that’s right.
On fire.
Half of the capital's subway stations had
suffered vandalism attacks and more than 20
were literally on fire.
They were being reduced to ashes.
To give you an idea, just the damages alone
from Saturday 19th cost an estimated $200
million.
(AUDIO: Piñera announces a state of emergency
in Chile after an intense explosion of violence
due to the rise in subway rates.
El Mundo)
But that was only the beginning.
In the following days, the situation got even
worse and protests spread to the rest of
the country.
Suddenly, supermarkets, shops, buses, even
entire buildings were being vandalized and
looted.
Chile no longer looked like the Chile it once
was.
Tremendously radicalized groups wanted to
end the so-called “Chilean model” with
a revolution.
Of course, as you can imagine, the police
didn’t tiptoe around this issue, they responded
swiftly, and with an iron fist.
That’s one thing on which the major human
rights organizations agree:
Reports ranging from the United Nations High
Commissioner for Human Rights to organizations
such as Human Rights Watch, have exposed a
collection of evidence which proves that in
many cases the Chilean security forces, the
Carabineros, used excessive force.
According to data from the Ministry of Health:
the emergency services cared for more than
11,500 people as a result of the demonstrations.
Of those casualties, 1,100 – so far – presented
moderate to severe injuries.
And that’s not all, there have been more
than 350 complaints about ill-treatment, torture
and abuse of detainees.
(AUDIO: “Factors such as the indiscriminate
and improper use of riot guns and shotguns;
abuses against detainees and poor internal
control systems facilitated serious rights
violations for many Chileans.
José Miguel Vivanco, director of the Americas
for Human Rights Watch)
(AUDIO: Protests in Chile: UN report reiterates
that there has been a “high number” of
serious human rights violations.
BBC)
In any case, just to be clear, there are two
very important details we have to consider:
First, we do not aim to condone acts of violence.
Not at all, quite the opposite!
These radical, violent, aggressive groups
that deserve all our condemnation had no reservations
when they attacked the police with stones,
benches and anything they could get their
hands on.
Even Molotov cocktails.
Not to mention the looting, theft, intimidation,
etc.
(AUDIO: “They have also been victims of
these acts of violence, in fact today, we
have more than 2,500 injured police officers,
some of them quite seriously” Sebastián
Piñera, President of Chile)
On the other hand, most protesters behaved
peacefully and many suffered the consequences
of a police force that was simply not prepared
for what came.
(AUDIO: Chile: Urgent call for police reform
after protests
Excessive use of force against protesters
and bystanders; serious abuses during detention.
Human Rights Watch)
Because don’t think that the protests in
Chile were the work of a few radicals, not
at all.
October 25th will go down in Chile’s history.
Eleven days after the riots broke out, according
to official statistics, 1.2 million people
took to the streets to protest against the
country's situation and to show their discontent
with the path the country was taking.
The crowd equated to more than 20% of Santiago’s
population!
So at this point we need to ask ourselves,
are protests of this kind really justified
in Latin America’s most prosperous country?
Well, I can already tell you that it’s a
very touchy subject.
[“Chile has a health heritage that has cost
us a lot to conquer and which we need to look
after rigorously.
It allows us to be a safe and healthy food
provider for the rest of the world.
We have free trade agreements with the world’s
main economies.]
(HOW CHILE HAS CHANGED IN 30 YEARS)
Let's start with the positives.
“It's not 30 pesos, it's 30 years.”
This has been one of the main protest slogans
that, little by little, have been justified
by the high inequality that Chileans have
suffered as a result of the system that has
prevailed in the last three decades.
But the question is, has this period really
been so bad?
Well, the truth is, no.
For example, take a look at how poverty has
changed:
(CHART)
Chile has evolved from being one of the poorest
countries in Latin America to fighting for
the number one spot amongst the richest and
most developed.
In fact, if we check out the human development
index, which in addition to economic variables
includes things such as health care, education
and life expectancy, Chile is top in the region.
(CHART)
Regarding inequality, Chile truly has a lot
of inequality, but it isn’t true that it’s
the worst off in this matter in Latin America,
not at all.
(CHART)
What’s more, it’s one of the few countries
in the region where inequality has decreased
the most in recent years.
This isn’t just my opinion or VisualPolitik’s,
this is coming straight from the data.
Because if instead of looking at inequality
overall, we focus on the inequality levels
between people of the same age, we’ll see
much lower rates of inequality among the younger
generations.
This also happens with education.
If we look at the whole country, we’ll find
that in Chile the percentage of the population
with secondary education is lower than the
OECD average.
But...
If we take a look at Chileans aged between
25 and 34, we’ll see that they are already
surpassing the average of the richest countries.
And this isn’t unusual, it’s a very common
feature in countries that have grown very
rapidly.
It’s easy to find very different characteristics
within a single population based on the generation.
One part will have grown up and lived in a
poor country, and the next in a developed
country.
But perhaps the best way to approach this
mess is that taken by Rodrigo Valdés, Finance
Minister in Michelle Bachelet’s second term.
We’re not talking about a radical libertarian.
Check this out, in 2018 this man presented
an article at the Harvard Kennedy School where
he stated two things:
First, that the left was making mistakes left
and right by focusing so much on the issue
of inequality because to combat it, economic
growth was much more important than redistribution.
And second, that in the last 30 years, those
who’d seen their income increase the most
were precisely those who had previously been
the poorest.
Check this out:
(CHART)
In other words, what the country needed above
all was more economic growth.
And that growth has been somewhat to blame
for Chile’s current problems.
Because as I said, it’s an extremely touchy
situation.
So do Chileans really have reasons to complain?
Listen up.
(THE ROOT OF DISAPPOINTMENT)
The fact that many things have gone well doesn’t
mean that Chileans have no reason to feel
disappointed.
Disappointed, that's the word for it.
Chileans were promised results that never
eventuated.
Despite everything we’ve seen some things
aren’t…
Well, so positive.
For example...
The country has a very low productivity level
that continues to hamper wages.
More than 60% of the entire middle-class population
live on the edge, they are vulnerable to losing
that level, for even the smallest reason.
And the economy, another of Chile’s great
points of pride in the past, has practically
stagnated, at least not in per capita terms.
Performance in recent years has been quite
poor.
And, of course, if there’s no economic growth
and real wages don’t increase...
Well, things don’t look so rosy, right?
And not just that, retirement pensions – another
of the great promises Chileans were made – are
very low.
To give you an idea, half of the pensions
paid in recent months amounted to only 123
thousand pesos, that’s about $160 a month.
(CHART)
Quite a miserable amount!
And that’s not to say that Chile's capitalization
pension system is bad, not at all.
What’s happening is that citizens don’t
really know how it works, because it has never
been properly explained to them.
On top of that the government hasn’t been
paying close enough attention.
You see, on the one hand they didn’t monitor
whether the total contributions over a working
life were adequate, and on the other hand
they never bothered to establish a minimum
safety net for those who wouldn’t manage
to contribute enough.
This combination is volatile, because people
write off a reasonably good system simply
because the pensions they report are very,
very low.
Which means the system becomes a ticking time
bomb as more and more citizens hit retirement
age.
Chilean men retire at 65 with just 18 years
of contributions, on average.
And for women it’s even worse, they retire
at 60 with an average of 13 years of contributions.
So, what have they been doing for the rest
of their working lives?
Well… informal economy, casual work, under-the-table
agreements they didn’t declare, and so on.
And let's see.
How can you hope to support 20 or 30 years
of retirement if you’ve only contributed
10% of your salary for 13, 15 or 18 years?
It’s impossible, it’s impossible to be
paid higher pensions.
That’s why…
If people don’t accurately declare their
earnings, the system simply doesn’t work,
not one way or another.
It simply doesn't work.
And if to all this we add the feeling that
social divisions are still very present within
society….
We can understand the enormous frustration
that fuels the protests.
Although if we think about it for a second,
it seems a little unfair to focus the discontent
on a president who won the elections very
recently.
What’s more, for the almost 30 years of
Chile’s democracy, the left ruled for almost
25, and they are the ones protesting!
I mean, they must’ve had a hand in establishing
the model, don't you think?
Basically, expectations aren’t being met.
And in a way, this can be explained with what
is known as Wagner's Law, a thesis that states
that the greater the wealth, the greater the
pressures for the state to provide more and
more social benefits.
And, of course, the smaller the state, the
stronger this dynamic will be.
But, now the question is, what’s next?
(THE LIGHT AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL)
I think we can now understand much better
what has recently been happening in Chile.
The question is, will this problem end?
For now, President Piñera is doing two things:
On the one hand, he’s launching a social
agenda that, among many other issues, will
increase the lowest pensions and establish
a minimum living wage.
That is, the government will top up the payrolls
of people who work and don’t reach 350 thousand
pesos.
On the other hand, it has been agreed that
in 2020, Chileans will be asked if they want
to change their Constitution.
Even though the Chilean Constitution has already
undergone 219 changes since the democratic
transition occurred.
The last significant one happened in 2005:
(AUDIO: “This is a very big day for Chile.
We have a reason to celebrate.
Today we finally have a democratic Constitution
in line with the spirit of Chile.
Ricardo Lagos, President of Chile from 2000
to 2006)
Well, he was wrong because apparently, it’s
no longer useful.
What can I say?
Beyond the fact that it isn’t advisable
to change the constitution often or generate
false expectations, what Chile needs is to
focus again on growth, only then can it truly
overcome all the problems it faces.
Anyway, I hope that this video helped you
understand everything that has recently happened
in this South American country.
VisualPolitik will be paying close attention
to see how the events unfold.
Leave your answer in the comments as well
as in the survey.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.